California could be on the way to its
worst wildfire season in the state's
history extreme heat and win led to the
formation of a dramatic fire tornado
near Corona yesterday it's part of a
fire burning in Orange and Riverside
counties the huge Mendocino complex fire
in Northern California is forcing a
two-week delay for the start of the
school year 18 significant fires are
burning across California John
Blackstone is at the command post for
the Mendocino complex in Ukiah John good
morning good morning well after almost
two weeks of intense flames on this fire
smoke is causing serious problems for
firefighters it was so thick on Tuesday
they were forced to suspend air
operations for part of the day and
they're now doing everything they could
on the ground to stop this fire from
spreading more than 4,000 firefighters
continue to battle the Mendocino complex
fires almost two weeks after the blazes
began so this is one of your lines of
defense here yes this is a secondary
liner for Cal Fire Battalion Chief
Russell and his team fighting these
fires has been like waging a war we're
on the battleground and we're trying to
make sure our troops stay safe but we're
also trying to save people's lives and
property this is one place where fire
crews have been victorious cutting a
fire break stopping these flames as they
came down this Ridge but they'll need
many more of these victories before this
fire is up crews have been setting up
multiple lines of defense clearing away
vegetation to create firebreaks they're
keeping a close eye on where the fire
might be spreading it's our hope is that
that plume will Klaus back on itself and
not Bend too much more to our north but
a bloom like that is what's helped this
fire grow so much over the past
absolutely a plume like that and then
you add a wind to it it turns horizontal
and the fires off and running
again the unpredictable nature of these
fires is why thousands of people have
been evacuated but not everyone has
decided to leave their home I'm gonna
stay and if I think it's going to get to
me then I'll leave it but I don't feel
that threatened right now now the threat
to homes is real this fire has already
destroyed 75 residences and more than
10,000 structures are still threatened
this battle is far from over officials
now say they don't expect to have this
fire fully contained until September
Gail it's a long time thank you very
much John Blackstone